surnommé le grenier du canada avec ses
vastes plaines consacrée à la culture du
blé la saskatchewan est aussi une
championne de la production de
légumineuses et de plus en plus on
cherche à transformer cette matière sur
place
environnement bien-être animal santé
pour répondre aux préoccupations
grandissantes des consommateurs l'offre
alimentaire évolué à la faveur des
protéines végétales
[Musique]
à saskatoon en saskatchewan le centre de
développement de l'industrie alimentaire
est au coeur de l'innovation et de ces
nouvelles tendances
dans ce vaste laboratoire culinaire ont
créé les aliments du futur on est
d'abord un produit qui imite le riz cet
idéal pour les consommateurs qui ont
dédié est faible en glucides
ce riz à base de protéines de poids est
conçu pour un client étranger qui
souhaite que son identité reste
confidentielle
la protéine végétale est aussi incorporé
dans une multitude d'autres aliments
élaborés au centre
[Musique]
c'est très excitant de voir tout ce
qu'on peut faire avec les légumineuses
des centaines de produits développés à
saskatoon sont maintenant disponibles
dans les supermarchés et le centre de
recherche reçoit des commandes de
clients de partout dans le monde
[Musique]
dans la cuisine expérimentale on met la
touche finale à un produit destiné aux
enfants qui sera lancé cette année des
bouchers de pommes de terre enrichie de
protéines végétales et de fibres de
lentilles rehausse la teneur en
protéines et en fibres
c'est destiné un programme de repas
scolaires pour améliorer le régime
alimentaire des écoliers le défi pour
convaincre les consommateurs non initiés
à la protéine végétale c'est de trouver
le goût et la texture qui plaisent voire
même dans certains cas d'imiter autant
que possible ceux de la viande sommet
québec
on peut par exemple imiter l'aspect plus
connus du poisson ou la texture plus
ferme du boeuf à belle cote
l' enthousiasme pour la protéine
végétale laisse croire que la tendance
est là pour rester
une bonne nouvelle pour les producteurs
comme les modes qui cultive des céréales
et des légumineuses à wrightson un
hameau situé à une cinquantaine de
kilomètres au sud d'origine a ici les
légumineuses font partie du paysage
depuis un bon moment déjà
les notes et emballés de voir la
légumineuse devenir un aliment
incontournable
les consommateurs canadiens découvrent
cassés lentilles qu'on cultive depuis 40
ans et qu'on exporte partout dans le
monde sont aussi bonnes pour nous de
quoi réjouir également le fils de
l'immonde joshua qui prendra bientôt les
rênes de la firme familiale et lentilles
occupe le tiers de nos terres et melior
ensuite nous rend demain de canola et
bleu
pour mieux comprendre limites nous fait
faire le tour du propriétaire
les terres héritées de ses parents
s'étend à perte de vue de soie noire
le producteur raconte avoir vu les
avantages de l'agriculture productiviste
mais aussi ses effets négatifs car nos
seuls étaient épuisés et pauvres il
fallait repenser notre système cultural
pour qu'il soit durable et qu'on puisse
en vivre convenablement pour redonner
vie au sol et améliorer leur rendement
il a introduit les lentilles les pois et
les pois chiches dans la rotation des
cultures
[Musique]
notre survie dépendent entièrement des
15 premiers centimètres de terre arable
sur lesquels poussent les aliments qui
nous nourrissent alors les légumineuses
permettent de garder la terre productive
à long terme
[Musique]
les légumineuses produite au canada sont
vendus dans une centaine de pays
en 2018 la valeur des exportations
s'établissait à 2 milliards 700 millions
de dollars
mais la demande est maintenant en pleine
croissance au canada
une belle occasion pour les producteurs
de réduire leur dépendance aux marchés
d'exportation souvent instable
[Musique]
l'avenir repose par exemple sur cet
immense usine en construction dans le
village de purdue au sud-ouest de
saskatoon
[Musique]
des promoteurs locaux ont investi plus
de 15 millions de dollars dans ce centre
de fractionnement de poids a dit vous
êtes en plein chantier absolument que
vous voyez c'est l'avenir de la
saskatchewan et de l'agriculture mais
les investisseurs se lance à la conquête
de nouveaux marchés
la vente de protéines de poids destinées
aux aliments pour la consommation
humaine et animale
un débouché qui offre aussi une valeur
ajoutée aux producteurs de légumineuses
[Musique]
le marché de la protéine végétale croît
de 8 à 12 % par année
c'est en plein essor la révolution
végétal est particulièrement marquée
chez les jeunes adultes selon une
récente analyse de la firme de sondage
nielsen 44% des millénaires you et c'est
d'augmenter leur consommation de
protéines végétales
même les géants de la viande comme
impoli fait qu ils ne veulent pas
manquer le bateau et se lance dans le
marché des substituts de viande
le poids est actuellement l'ingrédient
vedette de l'alimentation à base de
protéines végétales et une vedette en
matière une autre donnant lieu à une
annonce spectaculaire en saskatchewan en
septembre 2010 est le célèbre
réalisateur canadien james cameron et
son épouse annonce l'investissement dans
l' usine de transformation de poids
biologique veut d'une foule de quoi
stimuler cette culture dans la province
la multinationale française requête elle
a un projet plus ambitieux encore à
portage la prairie au manitoba
elle investit 400 millions de dollars
dans ce qui deviendra la plus grande
usine de transformation de poids en
amérique du nord et la frénésie pour la
protéine végétale s'empare également du
marché américain où plusieurs usines
sont en construction
cet emballement va-t-il s'essouffler
voit-on l'avenir trop rose pour garder
sa position de leader mondial dans un
marché de plus en plus compétitif
la filière canadienne des légumineuses
doit absolument innover dans les champs
[Musique]
c'est là qu'entre en jeu l'équipe du
centre de recherche en agronomie de
l'université de la saskatchewan
on teste au centre une multitude de
variétés de légumineuses qui deviendront
peut-être les futurs stars de la
province
[Musique]
dans cette serre un minutieux travail
d'amélioration génétique des poids est
en cours on induit de la variabilité et
on ne concerne qu'une infime partie des
plans en espérant que ce soit le bon
filon
les chercheurs sélectionne et croise des
plans qui ont des caractéristiques
complémentaires un long processus pour
obtenir au bout de sept ou huit ans une
variété plus performantes
la quête des scientifiques aider les
producteurs de légumineuses de la
saskatchewan à passer au niveau
supérieur
c'est à dire améliorer le rendement et
le taux de protéines des poids on veut
créer des variétés intéressante à
cultiver et productive d'acteur mais ça
doit aussi répondre à un besoin du
marché est très très bien
[Musique]
e